[Musik]
hier neben mir ist dieses mal also der
sich schon in unserer youtube story der
erste wert kann sich wirklich was
geguckt haben als abrissunternehmen
betätigt hat ja war er hat es nicht ganz
geschafft deswegen findet der leistung
dann doch statt sowieso sanken aber eins
weiß ich dann doch irgendwie komplett
unter gewissen vergessen zu machen
so ist so philippe ist ja hier
marktreaktion aufnahmeleitung
produktionsleitung auch alles möglich
ist eine schweizer messer von united ist
das größte land kredite oder ganz rote
jetzt so ein bisschen nütze
so also heute 500.000 abonnenten das ist
der absolute wahnsinn
ich könnte jetzt sagen ich hätte nie
damit gerechnet aber das war gelogen
weil er über monate verfolgte anstand zu
langsam
wir haben so im november
oktober/november immer geguckt wird das
noch bis zum ende des jahres klappen
wird es nicht klappt es hat geklappt
500.000 abonnenten und zwar genau in dem
jahr in dem klicks um zehn jahre
geworden ist total irre ja seit wann
arbeiten verrät ungefähr ja also wir
kennen uns noch von einer ganz
fantastischen firma media graffa viel
gelobt und fliege hass und sogar sehr
viel gelernt und sich sagen ja sagen
also nein alle sind dort ich glaube mit
einer menge erfahrung und positiven
dinge raus gegangen aber das unternehmen
selber war damals
jeweils zum stream einfach leute sind da
glaubten ja jetzt wollte christoph also
ja zehn jahre krieg so und wir haben
gesagt wir sprechen über das thema das
in den letzten wochen und monaten vor
allen dingen durch dieses in stella
objekt oder nur in aller munde war
aliens in außerirdische und da gibt es
ja nun die unterschiedlichsten ist
nochmal ausrichtung von aliens gibt es
nicht bis aliens werden wir heute oder
morgen treffen und wir wollen uns mit
diesen fragen heute beschäftigen und sie
beantworten
aus den recherchen die wir in den
letzten wochen und monaten angestellt
haben eine der letzten feier auch super
spannend und zwar geht es um die
sogenannten super viren
das sind viren die wirklich eine 1 1
erst haben was ihnen nahezu also fast
nicht ganz aber fast ermöglicht sich zu
vermehren und das wiederum astrobiologen
zur ansicht gebracht hat
könnte ja sein dass dass der ursprung
des lebens sinn ist also dass viren die
ersten lebewesen waren aber sie gelten
ja eigentlich nicht als lebewesen weil
sie keine komplette dna haben weil sie
sich nicht selber reproduzieren können
sondern dazu einen wird brauchen zum
beispiel mit der jetzt einen grippalen
effekt husten schnupfen und so weiter
hat aber das sind durch kandidiert also
die krippe die wirkliche grippe das sind
viren und die kann auch tödlich sein
also wir sind das ganz gefährlich ist
deswegen auch super viren
da haben doch einige feuer ziemliche
angst denn wenn ein solcher erreger der
schweinegrippe erreger sich dann auch
noch ohne wird weiterentwickelt
fortentwickeln könnte dann wäre das
natürlich wirklich eine wahnsinnig
schreckliche furchtbare krankheit okay
so viel also dazu und wir wollen uns
heute um alle möglichen fragen zu diesem
thema kümmern so und wir sind die vier
mal durchgegangen wir haben ja also ganz
wichtig noch
wir haben zu einem whatsapp da kann man
sich anmelden
den link gibt es hier unten in der video
beschreibung laura sitzung hinter von
tieren auf denen geht es gibt sie noch
whats app link geht es um eingriffe
also gibt es in der video schranken in
der video beschreibung also in ein also
in der wie immer sehr wendig und bei
whatsapp da kriegt er zum einen jeden
tag täglich den link zum video bevor er
auf youtube hochgeladen wird also bevor
das video auf youtube online gestellt
wird könnte das video schon gucken über
diesen link und ihr könnt dort
themenvorschläge machen fragen stellen
und so weiter und zu möchte ich mich da
auch und dann es ist aber keine whatsapp
gruppe das heißt wir können nicht
miteinander reden darf wir haben wir
dann einen diskurs server eingerichtet
dafür gibt es auch den link in der video
beschreibung und der könnte nicht nur
miteinander reden das ist wirklich es
ist aufgeteilt in verschiedene gruppen
verschiedene themen dazu könnt ihr da
könnt ihr miteinander chatten da könnte
auch themenvorschläge machen oder ihr
könnt ihn fragen helfen den stream
einreichen ich werde auch als erstes gar
nicht eine frage von pitstop server
nimmt und das absolut wahnsinnig es gibt
auch eine einsprache kanal werk also ihr
könnt dort eine riesige telefonkonferenz
machen mit unzähligen teilnehmern und
das ist schon extrem spannend was da
alles möglich ist außerdem gibt steht
ständig punkte und rollen und also es
ist ein ding übrigens dabei in diesem
zusammenhang vielen dank an clara ein
mädel aus dem ruhrpott die sich intensiv
mit der programmierung des disco servers
beschäftigt hat und den auf vordermann
gebracht hat dann ist wirklich eine
menge möglich also viel mehr als in der
gruppe und ist natürlich super spannend
so und wir kommen zur ersten frage und
die erste frage ist von disk ort und
vorher kommt dieser agent waren was hat
actor so extrem unser interesse geweckt
also ja man kann sich das interesse
wecken
wer ihn sagen sondern also viel liebe
und ich wir sind ja beide glaube ich von
dem selben schlag ist nämlich neugierig
und hat die meisten menschen sind extrem
neugierig philipp hat noch eine zweite
eigenschaft ist erzählt die
schlechtesten witze die es gibt auf
diesem planeten geht also wenn es ihm
gut geht dann werden die spitze immer
flacher
ja ja so erzählt also flachwitze aber es
hat neugierig neugierig mir nicht auch
und die menschen sind neugierig sonst
gäbe es keine forscher sonst hätte es
keine entdecker und das größte rätsel
wäre wahrscheinlich also ich sag mal zu
zeiten von christoph kolumbus war es die
deckung amerikas war bis dato kannte man
das nicht mal wusste es gibt asien
man wusste es gibt europa ist man musste
es gibt afrika alters war entdeckte man
wusste dass aber dieser kontinent der da
oben in russland im norden nur quasi
einen ein paar kilometer entfernt war
von unserem kontinent der war komplett
unentdeckt und columbus losgefahren und
hat dieses fremde land nach einer
ewigkeit entdeckt er hat quasi eine
riesige einen riesigen raum durchquert
um dorthin zu kommen und vielleicht
steht uns das im weltraum auch bevor
eine riesige strecke zurückzulegen um
eine andere spezies zu finden
und das kann und da ist die frage hat
großes kann eine mikrobe seien zum
beispiel auf enceladus dem mond den wir
in unserem sonnensystem haben und auf
dem ich sag mal die anzeichen so sind
was durchaus leben entdeckt wirken
werden könnte also an saturn mond und ja
es kann aber auch vielleicht eine
wirkliche intelligente spezies seien nur
die wird nicht in unserem sonnensystem
sein vielleicht und da sind wir beim ua
wir können uns das objekt wie es mal
zeichnerisch dargestellt worden ist
mal ansehen so hat man sich das ganze
vorgestellt als es noch hieß es sei ein
ja ein gewöhnlicher asteroid oder etwas
ähnliches ein steinernes objekt aber
dann kam der professor aber lobt der
nicht irgendein astrophysiker ist
sondern zufällig der leiter der
abteilung astrophysik an einer der
renommiertesten universitäten der welt
ist wir haben in der interviewt und der
sagt die idee oder die möglichkeit dass
es eine alien sonde ist ist auf dem
tisch um mal ziemlich korrekt zu
die tiere näher sagt nicht das ist es
unbedingt aber die wahrscheinlichkeit
ist sehr groß und das liegt der nächste
punkt den man bei diesem objekt mal ins
auge fassen muss er sagt die
wahrscheinlichkeit das ist ein
natürliches objekt ist wahnsinnig gering
wenn es ein natürliches objekt wäre
müsste es unzählige davon geben das
hätten sie aber vorher mal ausgerechnet
dass es eigentlich gar nicht so viel
sein können so das ist das eine argument
was dafür spricht dass es eben kann
natürliches objekt ist sondern ein
künstliches dann seine sehr seltsame
proportionen diese länge die rotation um
die eigene achse
die rotation hat man festgestellt durch
das unterschiedliche reflexion zu
erhalten und daneben eine beschleunigung
die dieses objekt erfahren hat als es ja
von der sonne angezogen worden ist und
wieder weggeschleudert worden ist dort
hat es eine hohe beschleunigung erfahren
als durch die gravitation der sonne
möglich gewesen wäre
es gibt zwei möglichkeiten dafür das
objekt ist sie durch die sonnenstrahlung
beschleunigt worden oder der andere idee
ist durch ausgasung nur die ausgasung
wurden nicht gesehen so und wenn man das
alles und jetzt sage ich ganz bewusst
journalistisch zusammenfasst und ich bin
jetzt seit einer gewissen weil der
journalist dann muss ich sagen spricht
eigentlich zu jung spricht eigentlich
alles dafür das ist wirklich ein
künstliches objekt ist und wenn man dann
und jetzt kommen wir wieder zu diesem
thema wo ist leben wenn man dann
überlegt wie viel leben müsste es
eigentlich weltall geben dann muss man
sagen hey die wahrscheinlichkeit ist
sogar eigentlich ist so war groß dass es
ein günstiges objekt ist größer als die
wahrscheinlichkeit das ist ein
natürliches objekt ist und so um es auch
mal sehen und da denke ich ist man eher
an künstlichen objekt so meine
journalistische meinung dass es nicht
wissenschaftlich sondern
ist nur eins und eins zusammenzählen ein
wissenschaftler muster ganz streng
vorgehen und er kann nur sagen das ist
möglich dass es möglich dass es möglich
mit den wahrscheinlichkeiten und eben
der leiter der harvard-universität der
astrophysik dort brennt professor blöd
sagt das ist hier mit wahrscheinlich er
hat ein wissenschaftlicher arbeit
veröffentlicht und sagt eine alien sonde
ist eine wahrscheinliche idee weil das
objekt eben ziemlich lang und wenn das
so stimmt ziemlich dünn sein müsste nur
quadratischen 0,9 mm also eine art
sonnensegel und ja und dann sind wir
auch dabei dass er einen an demselben
projekt beteiligt ist das so plant baic
starship projekt wo man mit ganz vielen
kleinen club sets zu zu einem
nahegelegenen sternensystemen alpha
centauri fliegen will das nur 15 jahre
lichtjahre von uns entfernt ist
und das könnte man mit lasern und einem
sonnensegel eben sehr schnell
beschleunigen mit kleinen satelliten sie
sehr leicht sind auf eine sehr hohe
geschwindigkeit beschleunigen und dann
dorthin fliegen und dann ganz schnell
vorbei fliegen vielleicht so wie dieses
der lage objekte wobei das war deutlich
langsamer
da muss ich mich auch im bezug auf die
anderen videos das andere video was man
zu dem thema gemacht haben korrigieren
das ist sehr langsam und könnte es in
vielen jahren noch von der erde aus
einholen wenn man eine höhere
geschwindigkeit erreichen würden aber so
würde man das machen das heißt es ist
auch spricht auch dafür dass es so etwas
sein könnte eine vielleicht ähnlich weit
entwickelte weit entwickelte
zivilisationen die mit einem solchen
schiff uns erreichen vielleicht ist das
ein zerstörtes schiff und das segel ist
ins trudeln gekommen drittes mal um die
eigene achse ist deswegen vielleicht
langsamer geworden who knows aber eins
ist sicher als journalist muss ich sagen
wahrscheinlichkeit ist da ist eine idee
und ist gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich so
worüber wahrscheinlichkeit ist das heißt
jetzt schon fast bei antwort wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass es
außerirdisches leben überhaupt findet ja
ist auch in disco gestellt worden und
genauso wie die wahrscheinlich ist das
wirklich leben existiert auf planeten
die kepler 168 ff also ob es genau 460 f
einer der
entdeckten exoplaneten von tausenden
inzwischen ob sein leben gibt das wissen
wir nicht es gibt halt viele viele
exoplaneten entdeckt worden sind wo
leben möglich wäre also wir sind viele
exoplaneten entdeckt worden
aber es sind auch einige davon betroffen
der sogenannten habitablen zonen also in
der zone in der man davon ausgeht dass
genug wasser und sauerstoff als genügend
elemente da sind und damit das leben
geben kann ob das genau die elemente
sind für leben da geben wir gleich noch
darüber und davon sind einige entdeckt
worden und jetzt ist halt die frage gibt
es dort leben mit welcher
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür gibt es die
sogenannte drake gleichung die drake
gleichung ist eine formel die kanzlerin
unbekannten und das macht sie so ein
bisschen problematisch weil man kann da
ganz viel einsetzen und man kommt zur
komplett unterschiedlichen ergebnissen
also geht es um die sternentstehungsrate
wieviel sternes dann gibt wo wirklich
planeten umkreisen wie viel
sternensysteme gibt es in den planeten
in der zone wo eben leben möglich wäre
kreisen solche doppelsternsystem sind
dass er nicht weil da kommen die
planeten durch diese beiden sterne im
zentrum er zum eiern und stürzen nach
der meinung der meisten wissenschaftler
irgendwann auf einen dass sterne also da
gibt es und da gibt es dann die ansicht
am schluss bleiben eben vielleicht nur
unser sonnensystem ganz weltall übrig
oder es bleiben immer noch milliarden
sonnen systeme übrig wo die bedingungen
für leben da sind und jetzt muss ich
auch wieder ich bin journalist ich bin
kein wissenschaftler ganz großer
unterschied aber auch ein journalist hat
ja die aufgabe und hat die schulung
dinge einzuordnen nicht wissenschaftlich
aber ich sage mal ein vorgriff und
deswegen gibt es ja auch ganz viele
journalistische zeitschriften wo ideen
entwickelt werden die eben nicht
wissenschaftlich sind sondern die
einfach mal was weiterspinnen auf
wissenschaftlicher basis und wenn ich
sehe dass wir eben selbst hier im
sonnensystem ich sag mal zahlreiche
möglichkeiten haben wo es leben könnte
zum beispiel der mars würde sich die
wissenschaftler der wo die wissenschaft
der ansicht ist dass etwa 500 millionen
jahre lang nach der entstehung der
planeten ist dort
lebensbedingungen gab die leben
ermöglicht haben also es hätte dort
leben können geben können auf dem mars
wenn wir auf enceladus ich sag mal alles
finden was für leben möglich ist dann
spricht das schon dafür dass es
wahrscheinlich und wenn man jetzt mal
auch von dieser perspektive ausgeht
wofür gibt es das alles warum gibt es
überhaupt das universum warum gibt es
etwas warum gibt es uns dann muss man ja
eigentlich überlegen wenn es unabhängig
ob es so etwas wie den schöpfer gibt
oder ob es nur die natur ist für hätte
man ja quasi eine eine gewisse ich sage
mal es gibt eine gewisse grundlage dafür
dass das sinn macht alles also wenn es
intelligentes leben gibt macht es sinn
dass es das gibt und warum soll es das
dann nur in einem sonnensystem geben
und wenn man sich so ein bisschen die
evolution her anguckt dann spricht
wahnsinnig viel dafür dass das ein
prozess ist der ich sage mal
wiederholbar ist dann spricht auch
wahnsinnig viel dafür oder ich sage mal
es gibt indizien dafür so würde ich
sagen ich war sie viel es gibt indizien
dafür dass lebensformen es gibt ja diese
berühmte theorie des space spams also
dass das weltraum spermas das auf ich
sag mal auf asteroiden auf irgendwelchen
objekten durchs weltall fliegt und auf
dem nächsten planeten landet und diese
ganz einfachen lebensformen und das
könnten als viren seien dort absetzt und
die sich dann dort weiterentwickeln zu
höheren lebensformen dass das dann eben
so funktioniert es gibt indizien dafür
und es würde sinn machen dass es eben
ganz viel leben gibt aber es könnte auch
sinn machen dass dieses lebensform so
weit auseinander sind dass sie eben
nicht miteinander kommunizieren können
also es kann wirklich diese diese grenze
zwischen uns geben oder eine andere
theorie ist ja die star trek theorie des
web antriebes in dem moment wo wir
diesen wort antrieb empfinden also eine
antrieb deren ermöglicht sich mit
höherer geschwindigkeit als der
lichtgeschwindigkeit zu bewegen
wie das geht kann ich noch darauf in dem
moment wo er das
neben aldi zivilisationen die auch
diesen antrieb erfunden haben mit uns
kontakt auf und wir werden quasi in die
gesellschaft dieser zivilisationen
aufgenommen
ich würde mal sagen zur nächsten frage
weil ich könnte jetzt stunden sport das
thema sind die friedlich sind die fand
die uns gegenüber gesehen was sie in
ordnung sagt ja eine ganz blöde idee da
mit den außerirdischen kontakt
aufzunehmen die werden uns sofort
überfallen
allerdings haben wir inzwischen so viel
ich sag mal signale in den weltraum
ausgesucht wendet sei es absichtlich mit
sei es absichtlich mit unserem
funkverkehr und so weiter und so fort
das eigentlich die fremden
zivilisationen schon auch uns gestoßen
war sein müssten und naja vielleicht
sind es wenn sie bösartig sind schon auf
dem weg zu uns und vielleicht kommen sie
morgen an vielleicht aber auch erst in
5.000 jahren wir werden das so eine
sache wenn wir die 600 lights erreichen
würde ich sagen dass er auch so ein
bisschen weihnachtsprämie sind noch
nicht ganz so weihnachtlich dann kommen
wir noch mal schneiden lassen oder nicht
bei mittel bei 600 x 600 leicht schneien
würde ich sagen wie soll es schneien und
sorgten bei den meisten weihnachtlich
aber warum sind der nächste block sich
hoher umsatz richtig geraten
kraftlos 9 24 uhr ja jetzt ok also
verdient erst zur nächsten frage über
danach mal weg und noch mal sagen wir
jetzt schon ja ich werde jetzt schon mal
gucken und das schaffen wir nie dafür
266 leicht 600 ist wenn wir nicht man
müsste noch sagen so nicht haben nicht
schaffen zur nächsten frage auf 6 104 o
jetzt wird das eben dass es schneit
meinst du dass wir da sind gegen das ist
nein ich glaube schon schneit
tatsächlich sind ja ja doch nicht
offenbaren sie sind
da sehen wir genau wann wir was wann wie
viel sekunden wir später etwas im live
stream
die sogenannte lateinischen all das ist
auch selber nicht ja schon wenn ja wenn
du bist mein gott seger was für eine
chance im internet drei jahren und jetzt
kommen jetzt muss mal plätzchen essen
was wir ja sehen möchtest du denn ich
stehe total auf zehn sterne und das
erste auch ein bisschen zu erlernen und
so lange stimmt genau hier und so
komplex sind welten pharma und islam man
darf ja nicht mit mehr als 100 gramm und
essen
hier sind deutlich weniger ich wollte
mal zwei fragen zusammen können
gemeinsamkeiten mit uns menschen
aufweisen optisch sprachlich bewegung
evolution und von dem youtube mitglied
ps oder peas haben aliens eine dna ja
also jetzt auch wieder wirklich eine
journalistische auffassung und nicht
wissenschaftlich war wissenschaftlich
wissen wir gar nichts wir stellen nur
fest dass es hier auf der erde bevorzugt
lebensformen gibt die über ganz
bestimmte prozesse ihre energie gewinnen
und das sind alles prozesse die mit
wasser in den meisten fällen zu tun
haben sie
pflanzen sie aber auch uns menschen
sprich es gibt vieles spricht dafür dass
osama ist so bestimmte grundprinzipien
gibt ein grundprinzip ist wohl wasser
woanders haben wir es gibt ja alle
möglichen asto biologischen forschung
nach anderen methoden eben wie kann
energie gewonnen werden wie funktioniert
das
es ist nichts anderes gefunden worden
als die form die wir bisher hier kennen
pflanzen pilze leisten sich genommen
eine sekunde die die eier legen es gibt
diese genauer und wir haben sind die
eier legen alle haben viel mitnehmen
also jedenfalls also es gibt bestimmte
prinzip prinzipien besser da was habt
ihr ja die vögel die sich stamm wir
glaube ich alle beiden von den 7
also jedenfalls also die tiere und eine
lebende wollen offen
so also es gibt diese form auf der erde
und es spricht sehr viel dafür dass das
sehr ähnlich immer auskommt und es
spricht sehr viel dafür dass ja ganz
bestimmte wo ich glaube er könnte jetzt
langsam aufhören wir wird kalt mit dem
schnee also spricht sehr viel dafür dass
es eine wirklich sehr stringente art und
weise gibt wie sich dinge entwickeln
weil es auch schreibt mir dass man die
kommentare es gibt nämlich es gibt
verschiedene entwicklungslinien wo sich
sehr ähnliche dinge entwickelt haben
also wie zb organe die haben sich wenn
ich das jetzt richtig sehen war gibt es
bestimmte sinne die sie in getrennten
entwicklungs zweigen entwickelt haben
sprich dass die umgebung die evolution
sehr stark beeinflusst sprich wenn es
nicht gibt entwickelt sich so was immer
die augen werden sich entwickeln weil es
gibt licht es ist ein sinn der einen
sinn macht und deshalb entwickelt die
evolution einen sinn dafür um diese
gegebenheit zu untersuchen wie es eben
die nase für gerichte gibt hier unseren
tastsinn unsere ohren für geräusche
natürlich ganz wichtig es gibt auch ganz
viele dinge was für ultra violet
infrarot und so weiter die wir nur sehr
schlecht wahrnehmen können manchmal
merkt es manchmal meine heizung nahe
kommt dann merken auch tschuldigung
infrarot und ultraviolett zum beispiel
nehmen wir nicht war aber soll auch
darüber keine niemand kommuniziert aber
es spricht sehr viel dafür dass die
sinne sich nach der umgebung anpassen so
jetzt und dadurch haben sich zum
beispiel was die beine entwickelt in für
für alle bewohner die auf der erde
unterwegs sind und die vögel haben beine
und die affen haben beine und die
menschen haben beine und so weiter und
so fort
weil das das praktische werkzeuge sieht
man jetzt auch bei der roboter
entwicklung um sich auf dem gelände hier
zu bewegen eben wo es wüste gibt wo es
steine gibt und so weiter und so fort
um das interessante ist es gibt da die
kreationisten sie sagen das ist so
geschaffen worden vom lieben gott dann
wenn man merkt wie dramatisch schnell
sich e volution entwickeln kann und
sieht man darf nicht vergessen die
evolution hat er hunderte millionen
jahre um sich zu entwickeln
und jetzt sehen wir zum beispiel eine
entwicklung beide fanden dadurch dass so
viel wilder gibt in afrika die einfach
jeden elefanten töten der 1
in der schlussszene hat werden jetzt nur
noch elefanten oder primär elefanten
geboren die keine stoßzähne haben
jetzt fragt man sich woher wissen sie
dass das dass man besser geboren wird
ohne stoßzähne es ist eine ganz normale
selektion sprich alle elefanten die
stoßzähne haben werden umgebracht strich
die kriegen kanal und keine nachkommen
mehr alle elefanten die keine stoßzähnen
haben die denn nicht umgebracht sprich
die bekommen nase kommt nachkommt und
damit entwickelt sich eine neue spezies
der
stoßzahn freien elefanten ganz
automatisch und so funktionierte und das
passiert hier ein paar jahrzehnten
und was passiert was kann alles sich in
millionen jahren entwickelt das ist
schon frappierend wie ähnlich die sich
die spezies und wie nahe die sich bei
einander entwickelt haben
man kann so was charles darwin hat es ja
auch den galapagos-inseln unglaublich
festgestellt wie sich da die
verschiedenen tierarten total
spezialisiert haben auf ihre umgebung
und das ist schon absolut fantastisch
wie das ganze funktioniert und von daher
bin ich der überzeugung dass da wir in
eine sehr ähnliche umgebung haben im
weltall das heißt wenn wir davon
ausgehen dass ist wasserhaltige planeten
sind die in einer bestimmten zone wo es
nicht zu heiß und nicht zu warm sind von
einer summe von einem stern entfernt um
ihn kreisen wo hast du noch nicht gibt
eigentlich müssten sich dann sehr
ähnlichen spezies entwickelt haben nicht
groß und dann natürlich will man es gibt
die können kleiner sein und haarig oder
ein anderer gesichtsform oder oder oder
aber so was wie gliedmaßen also arme
beine extrem wahrscheinlich knochen
extrem wahrscheinlich die lebensumstände
und ihren engeln jetzt also ich glaube
dass die planeten diaz spezies schaffen
erschaffen die auf ein leben und sprich
das spricht dafür und das finde ich
unglaublich frappierend und wir werden
es gibt noch andere ähnlichkeiten
das spricht dafür dass sich auf allen
planeten auf denen es leben gibt diese
spezies auch unseren sehr ähneln weil
diese paletten werden
steinig sein also es sind wasser
planeten dann wenn man natürlich so was
wie viel gelesen haben ob die dann
intelligenz entwickeln können weiß ich
nicht weil flossen und werkzeuge können
sich willig seine flossen braucht man
aber keine ahnung wissen wenn ich es
könnte auch intelligente fische leben
die dann auch in der lage sein könnten
mit weiterentwickeln pfosten dinge zu
bauen aus dem haus unter wasser
und vielleicht sich genauso entwickeln
nur eben mit geben alles möglich aber so
bestimmte grundprinzipien glaube ich
flossen braucht man alle fische haben
flossen bald mit flossen kann man sich
gut fortbewegen also es wird immer was
großartiges unter wasser geben auch
schildkröten abend flossen artige beine
unter wasser also es hat sich immer
wieder flossen gebildet weil die einfach
sich am besten fortbewegen oder ich sage
mal schaufelartige gliedmaßen oder eben
mit großen flächen und und deshalb
glaube ich dass die umgebung sehr
ähnlichen spezies schaffen wird mit
einer gewissen bandbreite aber schon
ähnlich und das finde ich schon glaube
ich dass ich also erstens glaube ich
dass das so ist und das ist extrem
spannend und das würde dafür sprechen
vor allem mehr darf nicht vergessen wir
haben milliarden galaxien im universum
mit milliardenschweren wahrscheinlich
selbst in unserer milchstraße unserer
galaxie gibt es wahrscheinlich ohne ende
leben
wenn wir hier im sonnensystem
wahrscheinlich schon mikroben oder eben
viren oder was ähnliches entdecken
werden da hat man jetzt gerade ein video
dazu wo eben die these vertreten wurde
das wären vielleicht der ursprung des
lebens sein wird nächste frage sonst
kann ich meine volk zu welcher folge
komme nicht machen wir nochmal einen
stream ab was kannst du dazu sagen jetzt
geheim
damals trieben wenn es nämlich nur für
die pens und für die mitglieder von
klicks und die haben einen link bekommen
einen ganz speziellen wir machen nämlich
um 19 uhr mit unserem geheim streamen
weiter also werdet unbedingt mitglied
oder patch 1 also unterstützt uns
das ist also wirklich toll die einnahmen
bei pixum steigen langsam aber stetig
ein wichtiger grund war edgar anfang
letzten jahres wo die ganz viele etwa
kaiser gesagt haben wir wollen nicht
mehr vertrag laufen dass es so kanälen
die pixum zu gut geworden und wir
stecken das ins programm deswegen gibt
es ja auch inzwischen livestreams wo wir
mit euch quatschen können haben wir
nicht eine menge technik für angeschafft
damit das möglich ist und stecken es ins
programm war es auch ein wahnsinns spaß
macht und wir haben den englischen kanal
inzwischen
da hoffen wir auch dass langsam die
einnahmen steigen werden das wird alles
dem programm zu gute kommen vielleicht
berichten wir waren ja in diesem jahr
auch mal am cern und vielleicht können
wir sogar nächstes jahr einen tieferen
blick ins cern werfen also dort in den
large hadron collider in den lhc den
größten teilchenbeschleuniger der welt
und uns den mal näher ansehen also seid
gespannt unterstützt uns ich kann da
versprechen wir werden uns hier in leute
stecken das geld in technik stecken und
in reisen und journalismus das muss man
ja auch mal komplett alleine angefangen
mit einem praktikanten immer als ich auf
wissenschaft umgestellt habe und
inzwischen haben wir hier habe ich eine
autorin die ganz viele skripte mit
schreibt nur deswegen bin ich in der
lage täglich ein video zu machen für
liebe ist hier leider kümmert sich um
social media wenn es jetzt da hinten
macht schnitt und technik und das wäre
alles nicht möglich ohne eure
unterstützung und deswegen dieses
programm wird fetter und fetter und
fetter und größer und dollar
umso mehr unterstützer wie suppe
bekommen und ich kann jedem hier nur
einen riesen dank senden und das gleich
nochmal ganz speziell an die betteln
sind mitglieder im geheim stream nach
diesen stil also werdet unbedingt
mitglied werdet unbedingt hat wenn
unterstützer ist geht für wirklich
kleines geld und ich kann euch nur
versprechen dass gibt alles ins programm
und weiter geht's mit der nächsten frage
übrigens link führen neue unterstützer
ist in community per bescheid wisst
genau die nächste frage die ist nun auch
schon häufiger über den weg gelaufen und
ich finde dass es teilweise auch so ein
bisschen so ein totschlagargument was
ist der sinn des lebens dieses wie kann
der mensch überhaupt arrogant sein wir
werden zu ziehen dass er alleine
existieren
ich glaube auch dass es ein riesen
denkfehler eltern
wir sind nämlich gar nicht so wie sich
intelligent siehe die der die
klimakatastrophe vielleicht finden wir
uns ja auch von der erde
runter es gibt ja auch die das ist
übrigens noch eine interessante these
dass alle zivilisationen die sich so
weit entwickelt haben wie wir sich
selber zerstören
ich meine wir waren schon mal ein paar
mal durch die möglichkeit atombombe
zünden zu können nah dran jetzt machen
was durch den klimawandel das ist eine
der thesen
es kann also wirklich ein evolutionärer
prozess sein man darf ja nicht vergessen
dass es macht nicht der eine oder die
andere machen ja nicht einzeln sondern
alle sind daran beteiligt das könnte
dafür sprechen dass es ein evolutionärer
prozess ist dass sich nach einer
gewissen lebens rate vielleicht gibt es
dafür auch eine formel und nach einer
gewissen entwicklung der intelligenz
eine spezies selber abschafft selber
zerstört wenn man muss sehen die erde
hat einige milliarden jahre braucht
gebraucht um diesen zustand zu erreichen
wo leben in dieser form und dieser fülle
möglich ist und ein paar grad heißer
können bedeuten dass unglaublich viele
arten aussterben inklusive unserer also
das ist schon arrogant und ich halte es
für halt total übertrieben sind hat
wirklich ziemlich blöde so wie wir uns
verhalten
und ja ich glaube auch ist es ziemlich
blöde zu denken wir sind allein ich
glaube da wird milliarden galaxien mit
milliarden sternen mit milliarden
exoplaneten wahrscheinlich haben
dazu muss man wissen als ich noch jung
war wusste man nicht dass es woanders
noch planeten gibt da hat man gesagt
okay im moment wissen wir nur dass wir
hier planeten haben wir haben keine
ahnung ob um die sterne im weltall
planeten kreisen und erst durch die
beobachtung in den 90er jahren wo man
dann zum ersten mal das verfahren
angewendet hat will gibt es regelmäßige
abschaltungen von sterne sternen und hat
dadurch die ersten exoplaneten
aufgespürt und so weiter und so fort
inzwischen gibt es eben tausende und
wahrscheinlich eben nur wie können sie
hat diese weise ich leuchte im gegensatz
zu sternen gibt es eben sind ein paar
tausend gefunden worden mit dem
verwarnung auch mit anderen verfahren
noch man kann ja auch die rotation oder
wie ein stern sich bewegt
kann man sehen ob der planeten umkreisen
also bei den unter schließen verfahren
hat man jetzt fest steht es gibt eben
viele planeten und das sind halt auch
wahrscheinlich noch mehr als sonne und
sterne und dafür spricht dass wieder
viele in der habitablen zone liegen und
dafür spricht dass es dort überall leben
drauf geben könnte muss ich jetzt sagen
aber ich glaube als auch es gibt auch
leben die nächste frage falls es
außerirdische als außerirdische die erde
bedrohungen wie kann man sich wehren
katastrophen ja independence day oder
nein also ich glaube nicht also ich
glaube wenn die zivilisation uns
wirklich deutlich überlegen ist haben
wir keine chance dann werden wir weil
sie werden alle gefahren kennen sie
werden wissen dass es hier wären und
krankheitserreger gibt die gefährlich
sein können oder sie wissen vielleicht
dass krankheitserreger von fremden total
ungefährlich ist sind bei uns muss man
wenn hier stimme die bisher nicht mit
uns zum beispiel kontakt gekommen sind
das hatten wir ja als bei der entdeckung
von amerika wobei da ist das witzige
jahr vor christoph kolumbus ist ja die
große ist das große sterben über diesen
kontinent gegangen über andere kontakte
und das sind dann ganz einfach revieren
die für uns gefährlich sind aber nicht
indem man sie wirklich die können dann
komplette spezies oder ich sag mal in
die spitze sondern spezielle menschen
die noch keinen kontakt zu diesen videos
dieser pakt er hat komplett ausbauen
weil die einfach keine abwehrkräfte
dagegen haben dabei bei uns inhalt gegen
masern gibt's abwehrkräfte in
übersichtlichen maße die masern das aber
nicht vergessen es gibt ja viele
krankheiten die sind absolut tödlich und
absolut gefährlich wenn wir nicht so den
großen umfang beschimpft werden gegen
masern zum beispiel wäre es eine ganz
furchtbare krankheit und die würde eben
viele viele menschen viele millionen
menschen töten und das macht ja auch
regelmäßig eine grippe
wendet sich an anfang letzten
jahrhundert die spanische grippe
millionen menschen getötet hat und das
passiert halt wenn eine kann passieren
wenn eine art mit einer art zusammenstoß
die ähnlich sind und die eine art an der
krankheit gegen die sie aber gewappnet
ist die andere hat diese erreger noch
nie der körper hat und die kennen
gelernt dass daneben millionen menschen
aber diese idee zum beispiel bei wie es
ist krieg der welten ist die idee dass
die dann irgendwer reger denn hier gibt
sterben ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass sie das nicht wissen also wenn in
spezies glaube ich ihr land werden die
vorher alles untersuchen werden genau
wissen was er isst und nennen sie uns
umbringen wollen was man ihn im moment
nicht verdenken kann wahr werden sie war
nicht zerstören
dann werden wir das tun ich glaube wir
können uns nicht dagegen wehren
ich glaube die werden so schlau sein
dass bevor wir überhaupt wissen dass wir
von denen überfallen worden sind ich
denke ich auch der youtube zuschauer
zwiebel esser was haltet ihr vom verein
paradoxon wäre die entdeckung
außerirdischen lebens dann nicht negativ
also also erst mal dass herr mit ware
boxen ist ja verdammt noch mal warum am
wall die noch nicht entdeckt die müssen
doch irgendwo sein wenn es um millionen
gibt oder milliarden
das kann aber wirklich wiederum dass
sein dass entweder ist wirklich nicht
möglich ist diese entfernung zu
überbrücken
es kann aber auch sein was es
intelligente zivilisationen gibt die
diese entfernungen überbrücken können
und uns aber nicht in kontakt mit uns
aufnehmen sondern als erst tun werden
wenn wir auch in der lage sein werden
diese entfernung zu über wirken sie
überhaupt geschichte das fahrzeug und
fuhr sichtung tatsächlich quatsch sind
also in den ganz ganz ganz wenigen
fällen wo sie nicht gefragt sind sondern
wirklich leute dinge gesehen haben diese
nicht erklären können gibt es bei mir
auch immer mal wieder meldungen
ich habe das gesehen und das ist oft
wirklich nicht erklärbar ausreichend
kugel blitzen zb und sehr interessantes
phänomen
ja also das könnte sagen dass es uns
wirklich beobachten könnte sagen dass
sie friedlich sind vielleicht ist es ja
auch so vielleicht sind sie in der lage
jedes objekt zu begründen und fruchtbar
zu machen und dann brauchen wir uns auch
nicht wir müssen uns nicht überfallen
warum sonst dann überfallen als wir den
einfach nur egal
und dann wird auch nichts passiert also
diese ansicht das ist eine veränderte
situation uns umbringt dann muss es ja
nicht unbedingt geben weil wenn es die
den ist die können ja auch den pluto
können da und rohstoffe abbauen sonst
hat sie müssen in die zivilisation dafür
zerstören also man muss auch nicht sein
außer es gibt sehr wohl sofort ist es
ein thema da kann man endlos über
diskutieren das ist alles ziemlich
spekulation wir wir haben einfach
überhaupt keine ahnung wie wissen gar
nicht wir wissen nicht was wie und was
und wann wie und wo und dann passiert ok
zum vermixt frp paradoxon gebe ich euch
mal ein shoutout braucht zeit lockt der
zukunft schotter vorbei der hat ein
cooles video dazu gehabt
und genau wenn wir bei außerirdischen
sind was denkst du denn werden wir
zuerst entdeckt oder entdecken wir die
zuerst wer macht das rennen
wie das immer wieder gerade bei dem
thema wir haben keine ahnung wir wissen
nichts wir wissen aber nicht wir haben
noch keine intelligente spezies
persönlich was glaubst dass ich auf
einem guten weg oder wir sind auch mal
fragen wie ich glaube aber werden zuerst
ich sag mal mikroben oder ehelebens
ähnliche formen hier in unserem
sonnensystem finden
was aber dann meint opening wird weil
wir wissen wie hey das ist gar nicht so
eng das ist ganz bestimmte bedingungen
geben muss es muss vielleicht ganz
bestimmte bedingungen geben damit sich
so was wie wir entwickeln kann
aber vielleicht sind wir eben auch
wirklich dass diese arroganz über die
wir vorher gesprochen haben
die bedeutet auch wir halten uns ja für
die krone der schöpfung vernichten aber
irgendwie eine ganz niedrig spitze ist
sie einfach von irgendeiner hören spielt
es auch tot getrampelt wird weil sie wie
ameisen sind
du hast sie interessieren sich keine
ausland also ich kann das nicht sagen
wenn es kann ja auch dass das heißt es
kann ja auch sein dass das alter des
universums bestimmt wie weit die
zivilisation entwickeln vielleicht sind
wir alle auf einem ähnlichen stand im
ganzen universum vielleicht gibt es da
gar keine so großen unterschied ist es
irgendwie schon riesen entwickelte
zivilisationen auf anderen planeten gibt
dann sind die alle genauso weit kann ja
auch sein gefährt weil sie die einen
sind noch vielleicht so sowas ägyptische
die bauern noch so irgendwelche riesen
bauwerke ohne sinn und verstand die
anderen bauten schon riesige
atomkraftwerke und den sieben und
verstand wir wissen sich aber vielleicht
sind ja auch schon ein bisschen weiter
und dieses bisschen weiter ist schon ein
riesenfortschritt für uns wie noch nie
wir wissen nur dass er nichts wissen
wissen wir denn dass eine frage aus
whatsapp wie würde eine kommunikations
aufbau mit der hirn stattfinden wie
würde man versuchen mit ihnen zu
kommunizieren und was würde man
versuchen ihnen zu sagen
also ich glaube dass das ganz schnell
gehen wird okay weil man kennt ja diese
berühmten touristenführer wo sie bücher
sind bett schlafen augen zu ich glaube
dass wir wie wir hier auch auf der erde
zwischen den kulturkreisen ja sehr
ähnliche dinge haben nehmen wir alle
etwas auf um energie daraus gewinnen
das ist zum beispiel das lebewesen
nehmen etwas auch um energie raus zu
werden entweder mit irgendwelchen
wurzeln aus der erde oder mit blättern
machen sie ein foto in synthese nehmen
sie energie auf wir essen zb und ich
glaube das ist im prinzip das man darauf
sagen so kann hier essen ehe ich nehme
was zu mir passt jetzt kann ich jemals
hochheben ja zum beispiel das ist ja
auch immer so denn so machst du dich und
jetzt nicht ja genau hier sehen sie
genau hier oder hier
ich weiß zum beispiel ist es überall
gibt es gravitation das heißt das
hochheben von dingen ist eine
gemeinsamkeit das hochheben von einem
objekt auf ein neues level ist eine
gemeinsamkeit oder das hier
2 das ist eine ganze sammler sage ich
hier 22 das ist in das ist universum
gleich die mathematik ist eine sprache
die es absolut identisch so und wegen
dass wenn eine spezies ähnliche entweder
ist wie ihr ist das dauert und paar tage
wir können miteinander reden das hat
total simpel kein großes problem
hier hat der letzten filme reiter zu
bekommen ja ja ja ich großartig weil die
sind ja auch so vorgegangen
mit wollen und genau das ist nicht
einfach
dann kommt man sehr schnell kommt man
kann man diesen ganz einfachen sachen
abklappern und dann kommt man ganz
schnell
und das immer wieder bei der evolution
da kommt man ganz schön aufs nächste
level und genauso funktioniert evolution
1&1 dann sind moleküle entstanden aus
den atomen das muss man auch nicht das
universum und das macht extrem sind
fällt muss man jetzt einfällt
universum hat angefangen mit einem ganz
kleinen punkt alles war in einem kleinen
punkt das ist es explodiert und dann gab
es noch gar nichts da gab es nur
strahlung und dann hat sich das langsam
verdichtet da gab es die ersten atome
dann haben sie sich dann erst haben sich
aus den atomen die moleküle gebildet und
so weiter und so fort das ist stück
weisen sondern ist immer komplexer und
immer komplexer geworden
das heißt das leben entsteht ist
eigentlich ein ein zwingender und stand
es ist zwingend es ist immer komplexere
wort immer komplexer und das macht total
sind das ist eben das leben über gibt es
macht total sinn weil es gibt ja auch
überall atome und ihr sagen was
wahrscheinlich einzigartig in unserem
sonnensystem also wasser wird es
wahrscheinlich woanders nicht geben nein
das kann mir gar nicht vorstellen
und so denken wir eigentlich wenn wir
glauben dass es nun eben bei uns gibt
das ist total bescheuert ja was auch
ganz gescheit ist dass die ganze wäre
ich vielleicht findet sich 1850 erreicht
wird sagen damit nicht
so bescheuert wie bitte kup gibt uns mal
1000 likes wird muss der christoph sich
ja auch irgendwie etwas anziehen
ja ich komme mir so ein bisschen blöd
vor ich weiß gar nicht wo ich hab' ich
glaube ich hab's nach vorne rechts
hingelegt da kommt nur dann gleich mal
drüber gott oh gott was geht wieder ab
was die wollen dich so sehen wir wollen
ja ich weiß es nicht genau
dazu können müsste ist video nicht
unbedingt leiden also nein macht das
nicht das ist wirklich keine gute idee
ist die sache mit dem wettrennen jetzt
auch die zehnmal weniger haben hier
nochmal das video
okay das ist jetzt wirklich ein bisschen
explodiert ach ich immer ein bisschen
verkauf jetzt und das bedeutet so
christoph sind was composites euro warum
das ist jetzt nicht so sollte auch
sitzung soll er sich selber auch setzen
machen wir die augen jahr sind du hast
du ja was macht ihr so was ist war so
[Applaus]
furchtbar
da sind das sind weiter
dazu gehört genau ja wir sind dabei
bekommt kann es auch gleich wenn du
möchtest tauschen will aber für die
meisterfrage ist alles sie machen meine
damen und herren moment moment meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren wir
kommen in der seriösesten
wissenschaftler hat diesen planeten so
ist es dabei ich finde man muss auch ein
bisschen bescheuert sein um ordentlich
was zu reißen oder danke
kommen wir zurück zum wettrennen und so
gibt es doch was neues was einer großen
entwicklung nicht hinein kipping noch
gar nichts nein ob jetzt einfach da
gibt's jetzt die arbeit sagt können der
sonne sein und das ist ich bin wirklich
das war so ein glücklicher zufall
ein kollege habe ich darauf aufmerksam
macht dieser app remote über den ihr
gerade noch zwei tagen berichtet haben
ist in berlin
und ich habe immel und hölle in bewegung
gesetzt um ihn zu bekommen ich habe
wirklich alle tricks angewandt da man
kein verrat ich hab alle tricks
angewandt und habe das interview
bekommen und ich bin wirklich happy
gewesen als das dann bei mir geklappt
hat also wahnsinn und das interview ist
wirklich passiert erst wirklich ein top
interview weil der professor wirklich
auch so wissenschaftstheorie mit so
nebenbei mal erklärt wie zb die
geschichte dass er sagt ja das ist so
als würde man zusammen am abendessen
tisch sitzen dann hebt man die tanke
rauch und am ende und man merkt der gast
der da hinten rechts am tisch saß das
war ja der interessanteste der hat ja
nur ihre geschichte zu erzählen
aber da ist ja schon weg humor ist ja
humor ist er weg geflogen doch oder die
geschichte mit sherlock holmes als er
sagt wenn alle möglichen dinge
ausscheiden als lösung und nur das
unmögliche übrig bleibt dann ist das die
lösung ist und das finde ich wirklich da
sind so ein paar super interessant
deswegen also unbedingt haben ja zwei
mal auf dem englischen kanal original in
englisch und auf dem deutschen habe ich
zu gequatscht aber ich hoffe
einigermaßen verständlich also unbedingt
ansehen ist wirklich ein der typ ist der
absolute wahnsinn also das ist der
erklärt wissenschaft so fantastisch ich
bin total überzeugt haben die frage rein
ist das jetzt ein sonnensegel gewesen
deine meinung also was denkst du ich bin
davon überzeugt dass ich bin dafür also
irgendwas verfolgen weil ich denke eben
was wir gerade hatten es ist aber dann
von uns zu glauben wir wären alleine auf
im universum
zweitens wenn wir nicht allein im
universum gibt sind und es andere
zivilisationen gibt dann werden sie sich
genauso wie er auf die suche nach uns
machen
das heißt es ist extrem wahrscheinlich
dass andere zivilisationen die sich auf
die suche nach uns machen zu und sonnen
oder sonstige raumfahrzeuge oder
sonstwas schicken
und wenn dann dieses raumfahrzeug oder
dieses objekt was durch und sagen
durch unser sonnensystem fliegt noch
eigenschaften hat die genau darauf
hindeuten da würd ich sagen hey ich
zähle jetzt mal eins und eins zusammen
da wenn man wieder beim thema 1&1 und
kommen auf 26 treme wahrscheinlich dass
es eben eine sonde von einer fremden die
zivilisation ist und eben kein
natürliches objekt mal dazu ja noch
kommt wenn es ein natürliches objekt
wäre ist die wahrscheinlichkeit das ist
durch unser sonnensystem fliegt extrem
geringen also und sieht gar die beiden
dinge da muss man sich nur mal 3 meter
das ist so meine these gebe einfach mit
drei meter zurück schaue mir das ding
mit einer gewissen distanz an und
einfach nur logisch denken und deshalb
bin ich davon überzeugt dass es eine
sonne an der fremden zivilisation ist
aber wir haben ja die chance wenn wir
wirklich ein antrieb entwickeln der
dieses objekt einholen kann dann
werden wir das tun und werden diesem
objekt hinterher fliegen und das
einholen und uns angucken also diese
chance gibt es ja dazu müssen dann nur
in den nächsten jahrzehnten einen
antrieb bauen der schnell genug ist
dieses objekte einzuholen also
konstrukteure weltweit
hier an der tu in berlin und überall
haupt mal richtig rein ich will jetzt
ganz bald sein antrieb sehen damit wir
dieses objekt an anfliegen können und
untersuchungen können also ich drücke
die daumen und ihr habt meine
unterstützung auf jeden fall wenn wir
uns auch über whatsapp oder so ne frage
stellen wollt dann guckt einfach mal in
der video beschreibung nach da sehen wir
wie ihr whats app mitglied werden können
aber kommt er dann auch immer die
aktuellsten video als erstes zu sehen
einmal das kostet 66 66 genau dann in
frage
ja ist man sich sicher hat dass man für
leben die kapitale zone und wasser
braucht oder kann eben auch komplett
anders sein als ohne wasser und in einer
vielen lehrern weiter entfernteren orbit
um einen stern geben
ja also nach dem jetzigen stand
wahrscheinlich nicht also man hat hier
auf der erde
und dann muss man ja auch sagen die erde
existiert schon seit ein paar milliarden
jahren und es existiert schon bei ein
paar milliarden jahren und es hätte
genügend millionen jahre gegeben damit
sich auch andere lebensformen entwickeln
aber es haben sich nur diese lebensform
entwickelt die ebner sehr ähnlichen
prinzipien ihre energien gewinnen sie
müssen irgendwie energie gewinnen und da
hat bisher immer wasser und licht und
wärme in einer ganz billigen einem ganz
bestimmten bereich eine sehr sehr große
rolle gespielt
es gibt ganz wenige lebensformen die an
anderen orten leben aber auch alle immer
dieselben prinzipien da hat sich nichts
komisches oder irgendwie seltsam es
entwickelt was ganz anders wäre
sprich aus dieser erfahrung die im
moment hier auf der erde gesammelt wird
darf gehen die astrobiologen davon aus
es kam damals ein paar querschläger die
haben sich aber alle als irrig and
wissen wie
diese ist auf der erde nichts anderes
entdeckt worden die prinzipien sind
erheblich gleich strich irgendeinem
moment kann man sich nur aufgrund der
forschung hier auf der erde vorstellen
das ist in der habitablen zone
existieren muss ja wie
da noch variablen sind auch die
vielleicht ein bisschen größer ist aber
der enceladus ist sowieso dass es warme
quellen geben könnte aber es kann nicht
sein dass zwar diese bedingungen da
ideal sind aber dass die engländer für
eine million jahre dort so sind diese
bedingungen und dann sich wieder ändern
und dann reicht es eben nicht damit sich
neben entwickeln kann sprich ist müsste
hat wirklich in dieser zone legen
und ja also im moment spricht alles
dafür dass es wirklich diese zonen sein
muss es gibt keine anderen erkenntnisse
ja schauen wir mal also ich glaube also
ich habe den einbruch aus dieser
entwicklung des des weltalls heraus wie
sich langsam entwickelt hat und immer
komplexer geworden ist es gibt halt ganz
bestimmte dinge die sie unter ganz
bestimmten bedingungen entwickeln
schwarze löcher entwickeln sich zum
beispiel nur wenn bestimmte masse
zusammenkommt unter dieser masse
entwickeln die sich nicht planeten
müssen immer in einer bestimmten
entfernung seinen stern kreisen je nach
größe damit sie nicht aus der umlaufbahn
fliegen und so weiter und so fort also
es gibt hier bestimmte gesetze und ich
glaube die haben auch einfluss auf leben
und das sprich wieder dafür dass das
wahrscheinlich so ist und seitdem
angeschrieben
im letzten video habt ihr berichtet dass
china eine sonder auf der rückseite des
mondes landen will
könnte es sein dass aliens ihren stücke
stützpunkt and ansehen müssen warum ist
seit 1970 also nach apollo 17 niemand
mehr auf dem mond gewesen hätten wir
nicht längst eine mondbasis alpha 1
haben müssen für experimente bei
verringerter gravitation oder im vakuum
ich glaube an aliens halte aber theorien
über elvis oder hitler für uns also das
ist schon mal sehr gut
die druiden alles kompletter bullshit
und ja die der mond die andere seite des
mondes ist ja auch kartografiert wird
ständig beobachtet wir wissen sehr genau
was dort ist es gibt keine alien basis
dort also die wird dort nicht gefunden
werden weil man kennt die rückseite des
mondes die das ist nichts neues seit
dort bisher noch kein fahrzeug gelandet
das wird sich jetzt eben ändern oder
keine sonder ebene gelandet
das wird sich jetzt ändern und ja also
und die frage warum es bisher keine
ahnung und das ding war zu teuer die
haben damals mit deutlich einfacheren
mitteln das muss man ja sehen damals war
die technische entwicklung noch nicht so
weit
riesige raketen gebaut und haben hat
diese akten so gebaut dass sie
tatsächlich in der lage waren ein extrem
leichtes raumschiff mit länder bis zum
mond zu schicken das war damals eine
unglaubliche leistung
aber sie war für eine volkswirtschaft
wie die amerikanische dann doch am ende
viel zu teuer deswegen hat man das
frühzeitig abgebrochen weil es eben viel
teurer geworden ist und das muss man
sehen
es geht darum dass man etwas baut was
dieses was in der lage ist eben den erd
orbit zu verlassen oder ein raumschiff
zum mond zu schicken sondern es muss
auch und das unter extremen bedingungen
eben unter mit antrieben die extrem
gefährlich sind extrem unsicher sind der
muss sicher sein und das ist unfassbar
wird im moment immer billiger
sie ist basics von elon musk
der ist inzwischen erlagen ich glaube
einen flug aus insgesamt so 50
millionen dollar statt das ist wirklich
ein schnapper das ist nicht nur noch im
das von dem was an saturn 5 paket damals
du hast gesagt
dazu muss man sehen der will ja nur was
in arbeit bringen also die bildwelten
wird schon wieder teurer aber trotzdem
im vergleich zu den saturn fünf flügen
ist es deutlich billiger geworden und
spricht jetzt wird es wieder
wahrscheinlicher dorthin zu fliegen und
die möglichkeiten sind jetzt inzwischen
viel besser weil es eben viel billiger
geworden ist aber deshalb ist wenn ich
es gab ja auch nichts mehr dazu finden
die haben halt ganz schnell auch
festgestellt hat da gibt es ein paar
brocken und haben ganz schnell
festgestellt was da drin ist und haben
halt auch viel mitgenommen und dann hier
untersucht und da gibt es einfach nichts
mehr zu finden also man muss ja auch
nicht hundertmal in die wüste sahara
reisen um festzustellen da gibt's amt da
reicht einmal hinfahren und da man hat
aus der ferne sehr viel kartografieren
kann sehr viel auch untersuchen kann
weiß man sehr genau wie der mond
aussieht und musste dann nicht nur hin
also man hat sehr schnell gemacht der
wissenschaftliche fortschritt ist
übersichtlich ab dem dritten viertel
mondflug und dann hat man zahlt gelassen
als auch extrem teuer war hat dann
übrigens ist besser entwickelt das super
billig sein sollte das dann aber auch
umfasse nicht teurer geworden ist der
segen unseres paper programm genauso
eingestellt ich bin dass sie gleich
jährlich aus 16
oder sieht das schicksal jetzt darf ich
mal der hochzeit ja na klar das sind
hier ja hab das auch abgebrochen aber
jetzt mit den neuen raumfähren es gibt
ja auch die nasa baut ja auch an einen
mit dem neuen raketen nicht raumfähren
wird es halt viel billiger und da wird
dann die eroberung des weltalls lohnt
sich doch wieder wobei da muss man halt
wieder sagen es lohnt sich wo kommt denn
der return of investment der wo kommt
irgendein nutzen daher im moment ist der
einzige nutzen dass wir eben in den
weltraum fliegen können dass wir dort
forschung betreiben können unter
schwerelosigkeit und dass eben nicht nur
für ein paar minuten wie den
parabelflügen sondern eben über monate
und jahre das ist schon interessant dass
kann man dinge erforschen die hier auf
der erde nicht möglich sind aber da hat
man auch festgestellt so doll ist das
nicht das was man am besten erforschung
kann dort ist wie ist es denn so ein
welt an wir halten das berghaus übrigens
auch ein super thema super spannend wer
hat inzwischen festgestellt man sollte
fehlsichtig im weltraum man wird fiktiv
also ist es nicht nur die kosmische
strahlung die ja auch super gefährlich
ist alles anderes auch gefährlich im
weltraum
ja also es ist ein schwieriges thema
also ist auch die frage ob wir unsere
neugier ausreicht so viel geld
auszugeben
wir haben ja gott sei dank haben wir ja
ein return of investment das sind die
satelliten aber ob wir return of
investment haben wenn er zum mond
fliegen wissen wir nicht ich habe
übrigens gestern abend sehr interessant
mit einem mitglied des teams was die
commerz den ersten kommerziellen
mondflug
ein paar jahren absolvieren will
angesprochen und da ist er interessant
die entwickeln zum beispiel ein 1 1
motor audi macht das und da gibt es
durchaus technischen nutzen auch für die
erde
es wird ein mobilfunknetz entwickelt für
den mond und da kommen jetzt andere eben
die auch auf dem mond fliegen wollen
sagen hat können wir das bei euch
lizensieren diese technik können wir
gebrauchen so und wenn es jetzt etwas
gibt was man auf dem mond ich sage nur
helium-3 könnte sehr interessant sein
als rohstoff wenn man da jetzt was
gewinnen könnte könnte das interessant
sein und könnte wirklich einen nutzen
bringen und einen return of investment
aber ob das der fall sein wird wir
werden sehen es kann es also passieren
dass in 20 30 jahren wieder so ein
rückschlag kommt und man sich sagt müsst
ihr als nächstes haben ja nur kosten ist
kommt nicht rein
und das könnte wirklich das problem
seien außer ganz wichtig wir stellen
fest
als ich bin jene endlosschleife
überhaupt nicht außer frage stehe auch
noch nie eine zeit wird die
klimakatastrophe treibt uns hier von der
erde runter wir müssen auf dem markt
oder sonst wohin
wobei das auch extrem problematisch sind
weil wenn man uns die mal angucken so
ganz lebens von tieren so mit dem steam
war es als erst mal letzte stunde durch
gerockt ist schon ganz ausschuss gewesen
und einige fragen beantwortet aber jetzt
kommt der kleine austrian genau damit
die das kommt jetzt noch da beschäftigen
wir uns unter anderem dem großen filter
den muss überhaupt naja das ist für alle
leute der link ist im community und bei
patrick
ja ich möchte etwas sagen möchte an alle
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer sagen
[Musik]